hier la plateforme amazon prime a lancé
une nouvelle émission love island avec
ma petite préférée nabila c'est un
programme qui nous vient d'angleterre et
elle est au contact des candidats nabila
et les accompagne tout au long de
l'aventuré regarder on va voir le style
nabila dans l'animation regarde elle est
belle elle et glam c'est ma nouvelle bff
même si elle m'a pas encore flou bacs
voici nabila si vous le savez mais moi
il ya sept ans j'étais aussi à l'autre
bout du monde pour une aventure où j'ai
rencontré l'amour oui est ce que vous
êtes prête à rencontrer l'amour je vous
prie d'accueillir logan
je vais demander aux jeunes filles qui
ont eu un coup de coeur pour toi de ce
avancé d'un pas et je vous rappelle que
dans love island il faut mieux ne pas
être seul c'est pour un seul couple que
le public votera à la fin de ces quatre
semaines et c'est ce couple qui gagnera
50000 euros voilée mais peut-il
highlander je vous revois très bientôt
à bientôt
elle est pas mal
elle est très bien bravo ou jamais que
j'y vois là je l'adoré bien sûr et quand
elle dit que la télé aujourd'hui c'est
poussiéreux qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors elle a 10 et poussiéreux chez tout
le monde sauf chez moi et d'ailleurs
nabila quand elle fera son retour à la
télé elle refera chez nous et elle ne
viendra que chez nous a dit voilà c'est
qu'ici voilà où elle s'éclate
voilà donc nabila embrasse fort ma
chérie nabila je veux dire non mais je
vois pas en quoi c'est original comme
concept leur talent et aujourd'hui c'est
complètement ringard et poussiéreux pour
faire ça sur une plateforme bien sûr et
on a déjà vu ça mille mais c'est ce
rapport d'activité par rapport au vote
ça va comme notre ami on pose des
personnages la chine d'aujourd'hui les
gens votent pour les couples dont mm
allez c'est bon merci sur l'émission
regard de la misère voilà on regarde moi
je regarde nabila c'est autre chose s'il
va regarder je lis pas nous faire
regarder mais je tique nabila